We Begin the day with a country under
renewed rocket attack from Russia as the
invasion of Ukraine goes into its eighth
month people all across the country are
once again hearing sirens and taking
shelter this week's air strikes the
broadest to hit Ukraine so far a dozen
Rockets slammed into public buildings
today in the southern city of zaparizio
the explosion set off a large fire and
killed at least one person the attacks
have destroyed vital infrastructure as
well as homes
a dash cam captured the moment that a
missile slammed into a Street in the
city of the nepro pedestrians rant for
cover and motorists took evasive action
the Kremlin says that the air strikes
are in retaliation for a Ukrainian
terrorist attack over the weekend a
blast that destroyed the bridge
connecting Crimea with Russia it's still
not clear who or what caused that
explosion today in an emergency meeting
G7 leaders promised to support Ukraine
for as long as it takes and they warned
Vladimir Putin against using nuclear
weapons for Ukraine's president
zielinski the Russian threat tonight
remains in the skies today he once again
called on allies to send his military
more air defense weapons
dear friends
prime minister trust prime minister
Trudeau prime minister kishida dear
president Xiao Michelle they also left
on the lion I ask you to provide
financial help for the creation of an
air shield for Ukraine millions of
people will be grateful to the group of
seven for such assistance
joining me tonight here at the big table
is someone who knows a lot about
Security in Ukraine her name is Kira
rudick she is a member of the Ukrainian
Parliament and leader of the opposition
voice party of familiar faith and we're
happy that you're actually able to be
here in the studio with us tonight the
first time we've been able to do that in
a long time it's good to have you with
us fantastic to be here thank you so
much for having me you are here in
Berlin and today the German government
confirmed that the iris T air defense
systems have finally arrived in Ukraine
when you got the news what went through
your mind did you say better late than
never or or too little too late
rather too little too late because the
huge difference between two days ago and
today are the distractions of the energy
infrastructure in Ukraine that would
cost Millions even billions to rebuild
and that would come again from our
European Partners including Germany from
our allies in the United States the
difference is huge it actually hurts me
a lot that of the eighth months of War
we still are asking for exactly the same
thing that on the day one we are asking
for air defense systems and for the
fighter jets because not only they will
be helping us to protect ukrainian's
territory but when we are talking about
the nuclear threat and I believe we are
all thinking about the nuclear threat
having enough of the air defense systems
would actually increase our chances to
intercepting this missile but I I do
know that at the beginning of the war
you were calling for a no-fly zone to be
established over here but so do you
believe that's that's not going to
happen according to the U.S president
he's not willing to go that far but he
said today he is willing to keep sending
these air defense systems to Ukraine if
you get the number of weapons that you
need do you have faith now based on how
the military has performed that the
military can create a protective air
shield around the country with those
weapons we will need my
President Biden promised us but this
would be a fantastic step forward
uh regarding things that are impossible
and not happening let's again recap on
the day one of where nobody believed
that we will be standing for more than
like two three days look at us now
second then nobody believed that we will
get the heavy weapons because it was so
dangerous to give it to us look at us
now then nobody believed that we will
get candidacy to European union and that
happened then nobody believed that we
will be on counter offense and look at
us now so I think
impossible things tend to happen when uh
there is like a resolve as it is in
Ukraine right now so I do believe that
maybe not right now but this idea of
giving us enough of the weapons to
create a no-fly zone for ourselves would
happen at some point
the prospect of peace peace talks I know
that President zielinski says out of the
question right now but today the the
Russian foreign minister said that
Russian President Putin would be open to
a one-on-one meeting with U.S President
Biden next month at the G20 Summit do
you see in that possibility there is
that the creation of a possible off-ramp
that we've talked about now for a long
time for Putin and a possible way to
begin ending this war
look into
conditions it will always go down to
this eternal question of who is the
security guarantor or that Putin will
keep his part of the bargain maybe not
even put in somebody else uh some
another leader of Russia because we know
very well what it means to make deals
with Russia we have been at war with
them for eight years before The Invasion
happened and we have zero trust most of
all we know that if they promise you
something they will break the promise so
for us to be sure that they would not
attack again they would be there should
be somebody else who will be saying okay
I'll make sure if President Biden and
the United States are willing to do that
that's great but I want us to understand
that would actually it would mean this
country going into war with us because
uh because we know that Putin will break
his promise I was asking you earlier
about the issue of territory and Crimea
and also eastern Ukraine the dawn bass
if it were possible to begin peace talks
and if it were possible to present a a
compromise what appears to be a
compromise Ukraine gives up Crimea the
Russians give up all claims on the Don
bass is that something that you can
imagine I know it's early but is that
something that you could imagine the
government in Ukraine would be willing
to at least consider
I don't think at this point no uh
president zielinski was very clear we
are not trading other territories we are
not trading uh on our people and right
now the pain
is
so deep and so unbearable for ukrainians
that I don't think that there is a even
a small space for for consideration
before we run out of time you're here in
Berlin you know that today the
international monetary fund talked about
uh possible Global recession but
recession here in Germany because of the
energy crisis that's resulted from this
war everywhere you look it seems people
are talking about
um problems crises that are being caused
by this war and yet the polls show that
people's resolve to stand with Ukraine
remains
um
do you have faith that that's going to
stay that way as the winter approaches
well first of all it's not the war in
Ukraine that raised up the energy prices
Putin ramped up them like a year ago
even when we we just started talking
about that he can attack and why would
anybody think that if the war would be
over that Putin will just become a such
a good person right away and will lower
them the prices does anybody like
literally honestly believe that I do not
think so so but I also know and I see
this in all countries that they visit
that people do understand that we are
fighting for something more than Ukraine
for democratic values
for our freedom and for this concept
that one country can just enact
territories of another country it just
cannot happen in 21st century and this
needs to be stopped and we have talked
with you that Putin will not stop
yourself that's true we are going to
stop him we we've had that we've talked
many times and you're right your message
has stayed the same that is true I can
say that Kyra rudick it's good to have
you here in the studio with us tonight
thank you thank you and glory to Ukraine
well Russia's strikes on civilian
Targets in Ukraine they are changing
little on the battlefield from the north
to the South the Kremlin is still losing
ground Ukrainian forces are pushing
their offensive in the south after
breaking through Russian defenses near
her song
Ukraine is pushing further east after
taking the Strategic Hub of Lyman and
Kiev has defeated Russian
counter-attacks aiming to retake lost
territory around bakmut
my next guest tonight is Samuel Romani
he teaches politics and international
relations at Oxford University in the UK
he's also the author of the upcoming
book Putin's war on Ukraine and it
examines why Putin opted for an all-out
regime change in Ukraine and it looks at
the future implications of his invasion
Mr Vermont it's good to have you with us
these missile strikes across Ukraine
that we're seeing this week
in response to the destruction of the
Kish Bridge
is that the the truth there or do you
see this as an attempt by Putin to
placate angry hardliners who think that
this war is not going where it should
well first of all there's abundant
evidence that now there was also
released by the Ukrainian Military
Intelligence services or Gore that it
was actually the defeaton lineman that
triggered this attack and that defeat
Enlightenment is very important because
it really brought out the criticize
criticisms of the Russian Ministry of
Defense from various hardliners and
those hardliners have formed something
of an informal block as publicly
expressing itself on state media and
telegram but privately exerting pressure
on Vladimir Putin it includes key
figures electricity and strong madram
kadira
as a former General and uh the Water
group had named Jenny Ferguson and these
figures may have also been important and
instrumental in the appointment of the
new Commander Sergey sarovicin whose
brutal strong-arm Texas in Syria are
being repeated now in Ukrainian cities
I mean what what you're describing it
sounds like Putin is a leader who is
fighting a war on two fronts he's
against the Ukrainian military but he's
also against
um the the Hardline pro-war faction at
home how much pressure is he right now
under to put on a show of force and and
to produce some results in what he calls
a special operation
well the ironic thing was that six seven
months ago the people assumed that if
the award didn't go to plan and Russia
started having military defeats if the
Russian economy was batted by sanctions
it would be the people of Russia would
be coming out in the streets it would be
the liberal the uh Pro anti-war uh
demonstrators who'd be out there trying
to call over Putin's overthrow would be
the election of colonies who might uh be
threatening the Kremlin that liberal
group and an anti-war group has been
completely silenced by Russian coercion
and repression and by the Relentless
diet of propaganda that the people have
gotten which has dulled them into
passivity and now he's having to deal
with the new Trey Elite small minority
that is very vocal and very very
influential by the look of women's
recent policies and Putin is a lot of
painter to that group otherwise I think
there's going to be the potential of
Entry Elite Rift or Schism inside Russia
would you agree that Vladimir Putin is
no longer in control of the narrative
surrounding this conflict
well I think he does control the
narrative and he also controls the
day-to-day operations of this conflict
very closely I mean he's taking personal
uh orders from the generals and he often
bypasses Sergey shakyu and Valerie
garasimov that's something that outside
organizations like The Institute of
study of War have uh talked about not
something that I've delved into my
research for my own book so who
certainly has control over the
operations in the pan as a non-military
man he's making decisions that are
obviously leading the country down a bit
of a dark path but militarily and he
does control the The Narrative but he
has to show that he's responding to this
group and that's what he was doing in
Kiev today that's why also he's ordering
the foreign Ministry to keep using the
phrase terrorists to describe the
Ukrainian government because these
hardliners have been calling for the
special military operation to be
converted into a counter-terrorism
operation for many months now what do
you make of the new commander of the
Special Operation
um who was appointed
um several days ago I mean he he does
not have a pretty past if you will I
mean he's
um he's accused of using chemical
weapons on civilians in Syria I think he
was in prison twice I mean is he the the
the hard guy the tough guy that Putin
had to put in place
well I mean seriously making is an
emblem of the corruption inside the
Russian military as you can see by the
imprisonments and there's been a lot of
scandals that have all of them as well
according to the year of time and he's
come from a very similar clock to a
previous Commander that they had I was
entered warnikov but dwornikov was
unable to convert his Battlefield
results from Syria into the Ukrainian
theater and remains to be seen what the
Sierra reckon can do the same I mean
clearly his track record much like
devornikovs does point to brutality in
1991 he was one of the only police
officers who shot demonstrators that's
what God and praised from people like
you have Jenny pagosian he was the
commander who was in control when Syria
got the majority of their territory
under government control and when Aleppo
fell but that was due to a lot of other
factors including the uh West and uh the
Gulf States cutting back the armed
supplies to the Syrian Rebel so he
really can't blame it for him but what
do you think we we could see though is
that when Russia was stalling
offensively in Syria engaged in
Relentless bombing and civilian
infrastructure to disrupt the anime and
then launch an offensive so I think that
these strengths will be happening more
regularly I may have seen Russian media
commentaries say that this needs to be
done for several weeks in a row
every day for the Ukrainian electricity
to be broken and you should launch a
major offensive so what he might do is
instead of uh trying to fight back with
mobilized forces and immediate Blitz is
you might bomb civilian targets for a
period of time delay the offensive and
then launch it when Ukraine's
infrastructures in total disarray or at
least that's what the Russians hope but
much depends on whether they have the
weapons or the missiles to be able to
carry that out before we run out of time
let me just ask you since you've
researched um Putin extensively what do
you make of today's news that Putin is
open to meeting U.S President Biden at
next month's G20 Summit
well very important is always open to
these kinds of meetings because he wants
to show that he's not isolated on the
world stage but he also wants to show
that the world's leaking superpower the
United States is still coming to him and
that's how it will be framed in the uh
Western in the Russian media discourse
it's exactly how on a smaller scale it's
framed with Emmanuel macron or left
Schultz or any other European leaders
were talking to him in the past so I
think he's going to use this as a
propaganda prior gesture at home to show
that Russia's not isolated but in
practice I don't think anything is going
to come out of this meeting I don't
think the diplomacy of Vladimir Putin is
going to accomplish anything in the near
term at least not diplomacy from the
west or from Kiev
send me over money from Oxford
University in the UK we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
thank you